foreign
let's go out to Robbie and welcome to
Miami Florida what's up Robbie
hi Dr jono excited to talk to you today
I am more excited to talk to you
what's up
um so my question is
how
can
um trust be
um restored and if if it's that possible
and how can we do it
what happened
um so I've been married for eight years
and when we had our son in 2019
um
everything was kind of you know slowing
down because of the pandemic right
and my husband
he he led me to believe that we were
going through some financial problems
and stuff like that so hey Robbie talk
directly into the phone for me okay
there you go perfect okay
your husband was leading you to believe
that y'all going through some
significant financial difficulties
yes okay and then so I picked up extra
jars extra shifts and I was uh you know
doing everything I could to help and
everything I got from you know from
those jobs I would give it to him to
help pay bills and everything
and then a couple years after I
discovered that he was putting the money
aside
and it was a large amount of money
oh like forty thousand dollars to see so
he told you hey we're broke we need I
need you I need you to get on the horn
so you have this newborn and you go get
one job two job three jobs and you're
working like crazy is he working like
crazy too
yeah okay so y'all are working working
and you think y'all are just treading
water turns out he has a secret account
with forty thousand dollars in cash in
yes what was he doing with that money
um well he said he was just saving it
for you know for
uh emergencies and
I I had no idea about this money or the
account okay I had no access to it so
kind of seemed
um Shady to me yep
and okay so we talked through it and
then uh we used the money to put down on
uh a down payment on a house for us
and then
a few years later uh he's doing it again
um
so I kinda what what is it about your
home that you don't know on a week to
week month to month basis
what the your financial situation is
what the bills are and how much money's
coming in like I'm trying to think how I
could pull this off with my wife and I
couldn't because
we share a checking account
and we talk on a regular basis about how
much money my paycheck is going to be I
work on commission so how much money is
how many books we sell right how many
speaking gigs I got so
um we I know and then the electric bill
comes and then the water bill we don't
have water bill because we live out in
the in the on the moon but we've got all
these bills insurances and things so I'm
wondering with you how would you not
know or have some context if he comes to
you and says we're broke we're broke
wouldn't you know like
yeah I I didn't care much you know
because he used to handle all finances
and
um I work part-time and use whatever I
got to you know take the kids for a fun
day or something like that so I never
worried about too much because I never
thought you know this would happen
and
now I'm more cautious of it and because
of it too everything that he does things
a bit Shady to me
yeah but hold on
[Music]
this is gonna sound strange but I'm
gonna kind of defend him a little bit
and I'm only defending him because he's
not on the phone if he was on the phone
I'd be having words with him but he's
not here okay yeah you don't participate
and in fact you keep your money
you have your job he has his job I'm
assuming his job pays for all the bills
of the house takes care of everything
and your part-time job just was fun
money for you and the kids
no I hope at the home too okay all right
so you're putting it in the central pot
also but yeah by your own words you're
not involved you're not participating
you're just putting money into an
account
and he says I got it and you're like
great I don't want to deal with it I
don't think about it
and so when he decides to handle it how
he wants to handle it because he's on
his own out there
and in fact most of the time people call
this show their husband has spent forty
thousand dollars gambling or on escorts
or something not putting it into an
account as a giant emergency fund for
the family
so I'm not going to say what he did was
right and he did it without you knowing
and maybe he said we're broke because he
has a goal of fifty thousand dollars
because he wants to get us out of a get
y'all house and so it sounds like
you all need a control alt delete on how
you all communicate with one another and
how you'll handle money inside your own
house
okay there's uh
okay
so we are not originally from the US
we're all born in um South America okay
and
um this money it was not in account here
so it was an account in his country that
our country the only him and his mom had
access to it maybe that's why
that was a big problem for me yeah so is
he sending money home
yes I know that's a huge uh I mean
that's a super super common thing that
people come to the states and then send
a ton of money home he just did it
without talking to you yes exactly
so
let me ask you this and this is a hard
question again he's not on the phone
only you are so I'm asking you and it's
not like I'm picking on you but you're
the only one here no yeah I understand
if he was to come down and sit with you
and say
I feel a deep obligation in my soul to
help take care of my mom
or honey I'm scared
bills are piling up I'm hearing about
this thing called covet I'm hearing
about this thing called inflation I
don't understand
um
I need us to have a season where you go
work two or three jobs I know you're
going to miss the baby but we need this
I'm gonna put in overtime
how would you respond to that would you
say oh absolutely I'm 100 in on our
marriage and on what we're building here
in the states or would you say uh-uh not
doing any of that
I know I will be completely on board
okay 100 okay
so the reason I'm asking that is
sometimes if our partner is not safe if
the person that we're doing life with
isn't safe
whether that's with Secrets whether
that's with fears whether that's with
money whether that's with whatever
um it's common that we create another
world just to exist right we have to
carve a little bubble of safety out in
our in our lives that doesn't sound like
that's happening here so can you rebuild
trust one thousand percent yes
okay but
you cannot do it without two thing two
key ingredients for rebuilding trust
number one everybody has to come to the
exact same table and put everything out
on the table
all these secret accounts
all of your wants and needs
he's gonna say I need to take care of my
mom and you're gonna say I want you and
me to build a life in the states right
you have to put all of that stuff on the
table
the second thing is if you say the
person who um feels deceived my husband
told us we were broke he actually was
secretly saving money so we could buy a
house secretly saving money so we could
be safe
the per but he didn't tell you and he
may have lied to you about it or hinted
around it and he was also giving money
to his mom without telling you whatever
we call that Financial infidelity okay
so let's say he cheats on you with money
and if you choose to stay
the second thing is you cannot continue
to beat him up every day of the week
moving forward if you choose to stay you
choose to go all in again also
yeah yeah I definitely I don't do that I
um I understand
is
um it's just I don't feel like
you know I completely trust him uh-huh
absolutely but have you sat down and
said here's what I need to trust you I
need access to all the accounts I needed
an accounting for all of our money on a
weekly basis on a budget meeting every
week okay is he doing that
uh sometimes he tries to get out of it
but yeah okay most of the time this type
of issue is not money related
this type of issues other things are
going on too
okay
is that true about your marriage or is
your marriage perfect other than the
fact that he's secretly saving money
without telling you where it is oh
that's right that's right usually this
sort of divide this sort of disagreement
on how we're going to be a steward of
the resources that we have it sounds
like you'll both work your butts off
y'all are both hard workers right
yes and you both love your you both love
your baby
yes we have two kids okay but is he a
good dad
yeah
um
sounds like you'll need to sit down and
say who do we want to be and what what
do we want this to look like
okay
um
if I gave you two tickets to the money
and marriage event that me and Rachel
Cruz are putting on here in Nashville
would y'all be able to make it up here
um there's 799 tickets I'll give you two
one for you and one for your husband if
you all want to come
it's a weekend it's a weekend marriage
retreat
that's awesome yeah you have to find
someone to keep your kids and it's in
October you can stay on the line and
Jenna will get you hooked up with the
details it's October 23 I think that
weekend if I'm not mistaken
um but we have a few tables left and
I'll give you one of them and it would
be a whole weekend on how to learn to
come together as a couple or talk about
sex and intimacy and all that we're also
going to talk about how to handle your
money and how to handle your money
together and how to dream about what you
want your life to look like and reverse
engineer that into the present and build
it Forward would you be into that
oh yeah that's awesome thank you so much
all right so hang on the line I'm gonna
hook you up with those two tickets if
you're not gonna come though let us know
because those tickets are really
valuable
um they are selling out real fast and so
if you're not going to be able to make
it up here I understand coming from
Miami to Nashville that's a that's a big
commitment both in travel and in getting
child care and stuff but if y'all want
to come I'd love you to be my guest and
we'll we'll at least give you all the
tools to put all of these questions on
the table that y'all are going to
address
but for everybody else listen if you
want to rebuild trust number one
everything's got to be on the table all
the secrets
second thing is if you all choose to
stay you choose to work hard to rebuild
the trust and I'm going to add a third
one you both have to be very clear about
what you need to help rebuild Trust
that's it
those three things have to happen if you
want to rebuild trust and then it's just
going to take time there's going to be
ups and downs two steps forwards five
steps back he's going to have a glance
she's going to turn over her cell phone
he's going to put some money and a thing
he's going to give money at his local
it's just it's just it's a it's a thing
y'all gonna do together as you grow
together
but can you rebuild trust absolutely yes